the defeat of a self-proclaimed God the
imminent death of the warrior nun and an
approaching holy war the ending of
warrior nun season 2 is filled with
unexpected Revelations
sleazy demon Adriel is the big bad of
season two and he makes for an
incredibly Vivid villain his syrupy tone
is perfectly emblematic of his Charming
manipulative and fundamentally deceitful
ways Adriel is a thief who steals the
Halo from Reya a being who rules the
realm on the other side of the portal
disguising himself as a human he is well
on his way to establishing his own
powerful cult when the first Warrior nun
Ariella skillfully tricks him he is
subsequently entombed for a thousand
years when he's freed by Ava and the
order he immediately becomes the leader
of a brand new cult Adriel is the one
responsible for encouraging Dr Jillian
salvias to create a dimensional portal
he lures her top assistant Christian
into his cult and uses technology from
Arctic to focus the prayers of his
followers making him Invincible he
proceeds to use that Tech to perform
apparent Miracles like healing boils
stopping a plague of locusts and
dispelling a fear-causing fog of course
he's also the source of these ills which
he creates using his cutting Edge
gadgets just when it seems like he's
powerful enough to trap Reya and kill
Ava the warrior nun summons the
Monstrous tarasks from the other side
they tear him limp from limb it's a
perfect end Adriel brags that nothing in
the human realm can kill him so Ava
simply brings over the thing he's been
fleeing it remains to be seen if he'll
actually stay dead but it's obvious that
his death unclouds the minds of his
followers
throughout season 2 Ava is in training
to defeat Adriel while she gains more
control over her powers which include
energy blasts and the ability to face
through objects they suddenly fail her
at random times the Halo just sort of
gave out it's not like it was running
out of power it's just like someone
flipped off a switch this is all thanks
to adriel's gigantic cross which acts as
a siphon for mystical energy even
prayers the uncertainty and
rebelliousness Ava demonstrates in
season one are gone as her sisters in
the order of the cruciform sword become
her priority she accepts them and they
accept her Ava resigns herself to the
idea of having to sacrifice her own life
to defeat Adriel Miguel who has returned
from the other side to kill Adriel tells
Ava that he's a bomb and she's the fuse
that will set him off Ava manages to
survive that eventual detonation but
she's mortally wounded in her fight with
Adriel and Lilith after adriel's
destruction she's content to die and
give the Halo to Beatrice but Lilith
suggests putting her through the gate to
the other side no one knows how this
will affect her but it will save her
life Miguel and Lilith both came back
from the other side and were greatly
changed but neither carried the Halo
what will Ava be like when she returns
we don't yet know
character on Warrior none has enjoyed
crazier swerves than sister Lilith her
main ambition in season one is to be the
one who receives the Halo after sister
Shannon is killed when Ava gets it
instead she's Furious and sets out on a
mission to kill her but instead a
monstrous tarasque kills her while she
hunts down Ava surprisingly Lilith not
only returns from the dead but comes
back with terrifying new powers her
demonic Claws and quantum teleportation
make her a powerful Ally for the order
when she returns however Lilith finds
her skin becoming scaly in season two
and turns to Dr Jillian salvias for help
Jillian examines the scales and suspects
a mutation of some kind but is unable to
provide her with any real answers when
Lilith goes to Adriel these slippery
manipulator unlocks her potential this
includes giving her sight that allows
her to see demons as well as huge
bat-like Wings in other words she's a
demon nun adriel's sweet talking preys
on Lilith's jealousy of Ava moreover
there's a kernel of Truth in adriel's
arguments about seeking freedom from a
capricious God who does doesn't answer
prayers he uses this to manipulate her
with Dreadful skill in time she becomes
more than a match for the warrior nun in
the end Lilith sees Adriel as the
monster he truly is and develops her own
agenda thus she warns Beatrice that a
holy war is coming and hopes they're on
the same side
the Betrayal of Father Vincent at the
end of season 1 is a truly wild moment
his story as a former Hitman and
alcoholic who redeems himself in the
priesthood is touching until it's
revealed that he's adriel's biggest
accomplice he betrays the trust of
everyone in the order of the cruciform
sword and continues to act as adriel's
right-hand man in season two Vincent
buys into adriel's rhetoric about
freedom and fighting the oppression of
the church however the more that Adriel
grandstands the more Vincent starts to
have doubts this comes to a head when
Adriel kills the pope father Vincent
grabs the crown of thorns which can
render supernatural beings powerless and
gives it to Ava instead of returning it
to Adriel Ava sees his doubts and
approaches him mother Superion spares
Vincent's life earlier in the season
this act of Mercy winds up helping
everyone as father Vincent AIDS the
order in the final battle against atrial
where the disillusioned priest will go
next is unclear especially since he
takes off his collar in the finale
one of the central plots of season one
is Dr Jillian salvias's attempts to save
the life of her son Michael who has a
rare blood disease notably Michael has
visions of adriel's Tomb the warrior
none and other supernatural phenomena
Jillian creates a mystical gate to send
him to a heaven-like place where he can
be healthy when she finally makes the
gate work young Michael runs through it
and disappears Jillian has no idea how
to get him back at the beginning of
season 2 Ava befriends a young man named
Miguel who opposes Adriel he soon
invites Ava to help him and his
organization very quickly Ava learns
there's much more to Miguel than meets
the eye this becomes especially obvious
when he helps her defeat several
demon-possessed people when he tells
them they're going to go to his home
which is a safe place for them to stay
they find themselves at Jillian's house
it's here that Miguel reveals that he's
her son the tragedy of the situation is
that while Jillian is Overjoyed to see
him alive she's also still in mourning
about the time she lost with him
unbeknownst to her his situation is even
more tragic than it appears to be his
only purpose in returning is to carry
out a suicide mission once again a
character who tries to play God Jillian
in this case is punished for her hubris
one of the most Slow Burn character
developments in Warrior Nan is the
friendship that eventually turns into
love between Ava and sister Beatrice
Beatrice struggles with feelings of
worthlessness and fears of rejection
because she is a lesbian she responds to
these thorny emotions with obsessive
overachieving when Beatrice tells a
story about a warrior nun who was gay
Ava immediately understands that this is
Beatrice's way of coming out to her
their friendship deepens in season 2 as
they both take jobs at a local bar in
Switzerland in an attempt to lay low
Beatrice is trying to train Ava but Ava
has her eye on having fun when Beatrice
tells Ava that she's never had a drink
Ava is determined to get her drunk they
have a great time and dance with each
other at a bar their budding love comes
into sharper focus when it appears that
Ava is dead from a fall before Ava
revives Beatrice cradles her and pours
out her heart as the season continues
Ava knows that their time together is
limited and kisses a shocked Beatrice
before sending Ava to the other side
they have another tender moment but
Beatrice doesn't tell Ava she loves her
until after she crosses over
[Music]
I love you it's clear that this will be
something that propels the action as the
series moves forward as their love story
is an excellent anchor amidst all the
weirdness of warrior none
mother Superion has her own journey in
season two she's a stodgy enforcer in
season one disapproving of everything
that Ava does and works closely with
Cardinal du ready to keep the order of
the cruciform sword viable however she
comes around and helps the sisters
invade the Vatican at the end of season
one season two sees her truly come to
grips with her past she reveals the full
story of how she held and was rejected
by the Halo while on a mission her
insistence on working alone wound up
getting the previous mother superian
killed her arrogance made the Halo drop
out of her body and sister Shannon
became her replacement this makes her
resentful of Shannon and even more
resentful of Ava later when Superion is
gunned down she confesses her jealousy
to Ava and the others Ava forgives her
and lies down with her Ava's unconscious
use of the Halo to heal brings Superion
back to life and makes her feel
healthier than she has in years she also
feels closer to the sisters than ever
before having finally admitted to her
festering feelings and personal flaws
one of the most entertaining
relationships in Warrior none is between
sister Yasmin and sister Camilla both of
them start season 2 as secondary
characters who need to prove themselves
and eventually emerge as legitimate butt
kickers in their own ways Camilla is the
youngest member of the order of the
cruciform sword but she's a brilliant
woman whose understanding of Technology
makes her a crucial team member even
when Adriel implants her with a device
that allows him to read her thoughts and
speak to her Camilla manages to turn the
tables on him by getting in his head at
just the right time Yasmin is part of an
order dedicated to protecting the crown
of thorns the weapon that temporarily
deprogrammed Adriel and allowed Ariella
to imprison him when Adriel is let loose
upon the world Yasmin tracks down the
order to inform the warrior nun about
the Crown's existence while guiding them
to the crown in a museum Heist Yasmin
quickly has to figure out how to
navigate the violent and dangerous world
of the order Yasmin and Camilla are key
players in the final battle against
Adriel Camilla takes out a whole gang of
thugs while Yasmin manages to stab one
of the leaders who bleeds out both
likely have even more significant roles
in the future
there are times when it's hard to tell
the difference between the heroes and
villains of warrior none this is
especially true of authority figures and
the show's Pope is no exception in
season one he's Cardinal Francesco
duretti a man obsessed with appearances
who clamps down on the activities of the
order of the cruciform sword because he
doesn't want them making the church look
bad but his manipulations and schemes
make it a little too easy for the order
to suspect that he killed sister Shannon
and tried to get adriel's bones to
consolidate power this suspicion turns
out to be wrong however just because he
didn't do those things doesn't mean he's
not a power hungry and ruthless man he
tortures one of adriel's spies to get
information grandstands at a meeting of
clergy to browbeat them into working
against Adriel and is part of an
institution that has Adriel asserts
killed millions of people throughout its
history the pope is fighting against
Adriel not because it's a righteous
cause but because he's worried about
someone stepping on his Turf next to
Adriel you are his ants
you will nail before him if there's a
God on Earth then what use will people
have for the church Adriel is presented
as a charlatan but he cleverly co-ops
all of the church's rhetoric when do
ready gets disintegrated by Adriel on
live television it's a declaration and
demonstration of power it's horrifying
yet it confirms atrial's claims
one of the last things sister Lilith
says to Sister Beatrice in the season 2
finale is that a dark future awaits them
there's a holy war coming
I really hope you end up on the same
side what exactly does this mean hints
are planted throughout the entire season
the nature of the other side the realm
at the other end of the portal that Dr
Jillian salvius creates is not exactly
clear its existence is first made known
when Adriel arrives on Earth after
ripping open a Gateway from his world
using the Halo he's pursued by terrasks
monstrous demons whose sole purpose is
to regain the mystical object Lilith is
dramatically Changed by her time on the
other side after she's killed and
Jillian sends her over again through the
gate what feels like seconds for Jillian
is days for Lilith who walks through a
desert until she's expelled by an entity
that does not want her there Miguel
wanders the same desert as a boy until
he's rescued by wandering angels and
taken to The Shining City he's raised in
Reyes court and trained as a weapon to
use against Adriel Raya later helps Ava
defeat Adriel is Reya a god demon an
angel or something else entirely is she
going to start the holy war against
Earth or will someone bring the fight to
her what are her motivations and
intentions regarding earth like many of
the most powerful figures on the show
her motivations are inscrutable and
absolutely fascinating